si el lleno y el lleno filo se
encuentran en la misma molécula puede
ocurrir una reacción de ti el sal de
intra molecular en esta molécula de la
izquierda ocurre una reacción intra
molecular para formar el producto de la
derecha y observen que se forman dos
anillos así que es una reacción muy
interesante lo primero que necesitamos
es identificar al bien y al bien o filo
bueno el lleno se encuentra del lado
izquierdo entonces estos electrones py
en color rojo forman parte del bien o al
igual que estos electrones espí en rosa
por otro lado el lleno filo se encuentra
del lado derecho así que estos
electrones py en azul forman parte del
bien o filo entonces primero mostremos
cómo se forman los dos anillos sin
preocuparnos mucho ahorita por la stereo
química estos electrones py en rojo se
mueven hacia acá para formar un enlace
entre estos dos carbonos los electrones
vi en azul se mueven hacia acá para
formar un enlace entre estos dos
carbonos y los electrones py en rosa se
mueven hacia acá vamos a dibujar nuestro
anillo de ciclo externo aquí tenemos
nuestro anillo los electrones en rojo
formaron este enlace los electrones en
azul formaron este enlace y los
electrones en rosa formaron este enlace
bueno ahora veamos qué es lo que tenemos
unido a estos carbonos en este carbono
que corresponde a este carbono en el
producto
tenemos un ch 2 y un oxígeno entonces
saliendo de este carbono
tenemos un ch 2 y un oxígeno después
unido a este carbono que corresponde a
este carbono
tenemos un carbón hilo y luego tenemos
el mismo oxígeno que ya dibujamos
así que tenemos un grupo carbón y lo que
se une a este oxígeno así obtenemos los
dos anillos
en el siguiente carbono tenemos un grupo
metilo y un ácido carboxílicos vamos a
dibujarlos recuerden que aún no tomamos
en cuenta la estéreo química
ahí está el grupo metilo y aquí tenemos
el ácido carboxílicos co2 h finalmente
el último carbono tiene un grupo metilo
ahí está el grupo metilo así es como
ocurre la formación de los dos anillos
ahora lo siguiente que debemos hacer es
tomar en cuenta la estéreo química
observen que este es el producto endo y
el producto endo necesita tener un
acercamiento en do entonces si este es
nuestro bien o filo estos grupos carboni
lo necesitan estar cerca del bien veamos
un vídeo del modelo molecular para
visualizar mejor el acercamiento en aquí
tenemos nuestra molécula y voy a rotarla
un poco con respecto a este enlace
para que el lleno y el lleno filo se
acerquen más fácil ahora tenemos los
grupos carbón y los cerca del lleno este
es el acercamiento en así podemos ver al
lleno y al bien o filo aquí tenemos una
fotografía del vídeo sabemos que se
forma un enlace entre este carbono y
este carbón y del lado derecho tenemos
una fotografía del producto
el enlace se formó entre este carbono y
este que corresponde a este enlace en el
dibujo y también sabemos que se forma un
enlace entre este carbono y este que
corresponde al enlace entre este carbono
y este así que en el dibujo
estamos hablando de este enlace en color
azul ahora pensemos en la estéreo
química del lleno aquí tenemos nuestro
bien y vamos a dibujar los hidrógenos
estos hidrógenos se consideran sustituye
entes internos y sabemos que los
sustituyen test internos
van hacia arriba así que corresponden a
estos hidrógenos que tenemos en la
fotografía y en nuestro producto los dos
hidrógenos quedan hacia arriba así que
al observar la molécula desde esta
perspectiva esos hidrógenos están hacia
nosotros y en nuestro dibujo este es uno
de los hidrógenos hacia nosotros y lo
representamos con una cuña y en este
carbono
tenemos el otro hidrógeno voy a
dibujarlo también lo representamos con
una cuña aquí tenemos el otro hidrógeno
hacia nosotros ahora los sustituye entes
externos quedan hacia abajo
por ejemplo este grupo metilo y este
grupo ch2 son sustituye entes externos
que en la fotografía
aquí tenemos nuestro grupo metilo y aquí
tenemos el ch 2 pero miren en el
producto esos dos grupos quedan lejos de
nosotros es un poco difícil de verlos
pero este grupo metilo está lejos de
nosotros al igual que éste se h todos
entonces en nuestro producto aquí
tenemos el grupo metilo y aquí tenemos
el ch todos ahora pensemos en la estéreo
química del yen o filo a mí me gusta
dibujar una línea para analizar los dos
lados del doble enlace primero veamos
que tenemos del lado izquierdo aquí
tenemos un ácido carboxílicos y también
tenemos este grupo carbón y lo es
difícil verlo pero se encuentra justo
aquí y el ácido carboxílicos corresponde
a esta esfera roja entonces esos dos
grupos terminaron del mismo lado y se
encuentran inicialmente del lado
izquierdo de la línea por lo tanto en la
fotografía del producto aquí tenemos el
ácido carboxílicos que está lejos de
nosotros y este enlace del carbón y lo
está lejos de nosotros vamos a
localizarlos en el dibujo
aquí está el carbón y lo observen que se
encuentra lejos de nosotros porque está
representado con esta línea punteada y
aquí tenemos el ácido carboxílicos que
también está lejos de nosotros así que
estos dos grupos terminaron del mismo
lado del anillo y en este caso quedaron
hacia abajo pero ahora analicemos lo que
tenemos del lado derecho del doble
enlace bueno aquí tenemos un hidrógeno
tenemos un hidrógeno y un grupo metilo
entonces aquí está el grupo metilo que
es de color amarillo y aquí tenemos el
hidrógeno así que todo lo que tenemos
del lado derecho termina hacia arriba
observen que en el producto el hidrógeno
queda hacia arriba y es un poco difícil
ver el grupo metilo pero también se
encuentra hacia arriba y en nuestro
dibujo bueno aquí tenemos el hidrógeno y
aquí tenemos el grupo metilo entonces
todos
que tengamos del lado derecho del doble
enlace termina hacia arriba y todo lo
que tengamos del lado izquierdo en este
acercamiento endo termina hacia abajo